For us,
query will be the most complex of
the required content provider methods.
We've given you the bones,
of the query operation.
As you can see,
we use our SURI nature object,
once again to switch on the type of URI.
Note that each response from this
function, will return a cursor that
corresponds to the incoming
query as defined by the URI.
This is the only function where we
will have to fill out a different
response for every type of
URI in the content provider,
as several of them
are used in queries only.
At the bottom of our function, we're
going to set the notification URI for
our cursor to the one that
was passed into the function.
This causes the cursor to register
a content observer, to watch for
changes that happen to that URI and
any of its descendants.
This allows the content provider,
to easily tell the UI when the cursor
changes, on operations like
a database insert or update.
We'll see more on this later,
when we cover inserting and
updating the database.
Uncomment the test basic weather query
function within test provider and
run this code when you're finished, to
make sure all of this is working well.